In the last question in the last homework of the
course, we were asked to just define a web page
that uses some HTML and JavaScript. So if you
ran it, you got this default, this comes in a
placeholder text that we gave you and we invite
you to use some creativity and have fun with your
brother. Someone who knew just that. So I
wasn’t very creative. I adapted the code
from a website you may have heard of called
searchwithpeter.info to match the context of our
web browser and also to add a bit of JavaScript
that will work in a JavaScript interpreter. And the
result of that, I used a header, some paragraph
tags, a link, an image, I used strong to make that
bigger and this was generated by JavaScript
execution, which isn’t very complicated. Udacity
equals true if Udacity write it out and some
of the P tags as we are going to interpret
it which is what we did in question two.